[MUSIC PLAYING]
AJA HAMMERLY: Hi.
So just to make sure
everyone's in the right place,
this is App Dev 201--
DevOps for Application
Developers.
I'm Aja.
I'm not going to
have a lot of time
after the talk for questions.
I thought I would, but
there's too much content
to share with you guys today.
So if you have
questions, I encourage
you to tweet them at me.
I am the_thagomizer,
which is the spiky part
at the end of a stegosaurus.
And I have my DMs open.
If you don't want to share
your question publicly,
I will try to get to them
tonight at some point.
Sorry, I can't do
questions live.
So who's this talk for?
So this talk is for
folks who have an MVP.
You've got something
that's super cool.
You think it's going to
be the next giant thing.
But you have no idea how
to get it to production
in a safe and stable way.
Or maybe you're new to GCP.
This event got a lot
bigger this year,
so I'm assuming that some
of you are new, maybe?
Maybe you're one of those people
who just want a well-worn path
to follow.
When I was doing
consulting, we had one way
that we shipped
most of our web apps
because we knew it,
we knew it worked,
we knew how to do it right.
And so we used it
as much as we could.
It was our well-worn path.
So I'm going to try
to give you some ideas
of some well-worn paths on GCP.
And this talk is especially
for folks with minimal DevOps
experience who want to
know just enough that they
can make cool things and make
them available for other people
to use them.
So what's this talk about?
The title is decidedly vague.
This talk is about
"productionizing"
and application.
We're going to talk about
your compute options on GCP.
We're going to talk
about monitoring,
application performance
monitoring, specifically.
And then, at the very end,
there's going to be a recap.
We're going to give all
the information again,
so that you can see it twice.
And the AV team has been really
good about getting the talks
up on YouTube very, very
quickly so you don't feel
like you have to take notes.
You will likely be able to see
this again at your own pace
tomorrow.
And so I'm going to do something
a little different here.
Every time I've given a
talk like this in the past,
I've been, like, this is
one of your compute options,
this is what it's good at,
this is what it's not good at.
But that didn't really work
for me with a narrative flow.
I found it really boring,
and it didn't actually
help folks make good decisions.
So I flipped that on
its head for this talk.
And the entire talk is going
to be based around questions.
I have seven
questions that I think
everyone should ask
themselves if they're
taking an app to production.
And they're not yes
or no questions,
so they're going to make
you think a little bit.
I hope to eventually do a blog
series about these questions
because there's a
lot more that I'd
like to cover that I can't
get to in the time allowed.
So please bear with
me if the format
doesn't work for your brain.
Hopefully, for some of
you, it works better
than the standard format.
It works really well for me.
So question number one--
question number one is,
what are my priorities?
If you're shipping something,
you have priorities.
And priorities are super
important because everything
in the DevOps/SRE
world is a trade-off.
The most secure,
bug-free website
is one that doesn't exist,
and doesn't have any users,
and was never published.
And none of us want that.
So you're going to have to
have some downtime probably--
maybe not a lot, maybe only
milliseconds every year.
But you're going to
probably have some downtime.
You're going to have to make
some sacrifices of how fast you
can move for robustness
or maybe how much you're
willing to spend for how easy
to use your application platform
is.
So you need to think
about your priorities.
Some examples of priorities is,
maybe you're very early stage,
and you're demoing to
potential investors.
OK.
There's a different
set of priorities
for that than if you're in
beta testing or early access
or maybe even ready to go live.
Maybe your biggest priority
is saving money-- no shame.
No shame in saving money.
I have worked at a startup.
I've worked at a startup
that nearly ran out of money.
I get it.
But you have to make sure
that you're aware of the fact
that that's your priority,
so you can make decisions
with that in mind.
Or maybe your priority
is robustness.
Maybe you are
working on something
where any downtime is
going to be a problem.
Well, you're going to
make some decisions that
are based on that,
and they're going
to have other
consequences elsewhere.
So think really hard about
what your priorities are.
Make sure you put
them in some sort
of approximate,
stack-ranked order
because those
priorities are going
to influence your choices.
Your compute environment--
well, some compute environments
are cheaper.
Generally, not always
true, but frequently,
more-managed solutions are
slightly more expensive
than less-managed solutions,
but you're sacrificing time.
Maybe that's the right
trade-off for you.
If you need a lot of
robustness, maybe you
need a lot of monitoring.
If you mostly don't
care, maybe you don't.
If you're early stage,
perhaps that's all you need.
Maybe you work in
an industry that
has stringent
audit-logging requirements.
Well, logging is going
to be a priority for you.
Maybe you don't write
particularly good code like me,
or you know you're jamming
this out at the last minute,
and so there's going to
be problems in production.
So being able to debug
or trace and figure out
what you did that's
making everything explode,
like my demo downstairs did
yesterday, is important.
And maybe you need
disaster recovery.
This is something that nobody
thinks of until something goes
wrong, like, there's an outage.
And then you're like, oh
right, that's the thing--
yeah, I was supposed to do that.
So make sure you think
about that up front.
A lot of places don't need
it, especially early on.
But you might get to
a point where you do.
So that was question one--
priorities-- nothing actually
technical there.
We're going to get slightly
more technical as we go on.
The second question is,
what does my load look like?
So I've worked at a bunch
of different places.
I've probably had every job
title that's common in tech
at this point.
And I had a company I worked
at where we only got load
during the school day because
we were an education product.
So weekends-- no use.
Midnight-- no use.
9:00 to 3:00-- lots of use.
So we had different
load requirements
than an app that has a pretty
steady use case or an app that
might have special work
it does late at night
to do a bunch of computations or
a bunch of predictive modeling.
I worked at this website once
where we were doing a release,
and we had done a
green-blue-type deployment.
We didn't call it
that back then,
because I've been
doing this for a while.
And we realized that
9:00 AM on Saturdays
was our highest load we
ever got during the week.
And that's when we were trying
to bring the site back up.
And half of the cluster
was not actually
sufficient to support the
entire load, so we went down.
So that was a good lesson for
us to learn about load, also
a good lesson for us to
learn about headspace.
But you need to think about
what your load looks like.
And this is a question you
should be asking yourself
on a somewhat regular basis.
Depending on how fast you're
growing, it could be quarterly;
it could be yearly.
But you need to be thinking
about what your load looks
like because that's going
to influence your technology
choices.
So your load is going to
influence your choices.
I just said that.
If you have a very
variable load--
so something that's a lot during
some periods and none at all
during others--
sinusoid-type thing--
you're going to probably want
something that's autoscaling.
On GCP, we have lots of those.
We have App Engine, which is
the one that most people know--
been around for a
really long time--
10 years.
We have Google Kubernetes
Engine, which also autoscales.
I'm using that for one of
the installations downstairs
in the showcase floor.
People don't frequently
know that Google Compute
Engine will also autoscale.
You can set up managed instance
groups on Google Compute Engine
and say, it should be something
between here and here.
And it will auto
scale those for you.
It will make more
as you need them,
take them down as you don't.
And my new favoritest thing
ever, Google Cloud Functions,
also autoscales because
it's functions as a service,
and that's kind of what it does.
It does units of work, and
you can do lots of them
or very few of them,
and it's great.
If you have periods
of time where
you don't want your website
up or your website probably
doesn't need to be up, like,
if you're in that still really
early-on investor
stage where you're only
going to give them access for a
couple of days, scaling to zero
is likely important.
So if you're going to
need to scale to zero,
your choices are App Engine
Standard or Google Cloud
Functions.
Lots of people don't actually
need to scale to zero,
but if you need it, it's a
fantastic way to save money.
So if money is a priority, you
might consider that as well.
And then, if you're
setting up autoscaling,
you need to put bumpers.
You need to say, this
is the minimum size,
this is the maximum size.
And to do that, you have to
know approximately how big
your cluster might need to get.
That's why we need to know
about how many users we're going
to have on a regular basis.
The factor I've always used
in my professional career--
and I don't know if this is
endorsed by any Google SRE,
because I am not a Google SRE--
is 2x of the worst
case scenario.
Now, there is a case
study on our blog
where 5x of the
worst case scenario
was not actually sufficient.
So know your use.
Know how stuff's going to grow.
I have had an app that went on
a morning TV show in the US.
And we way
overprovisioned for that.
We actually kicked it
up to 4x just in case
it went really, really well.
And the nice thing
about autoscaling stuff
is you can say, OK, just for
this day, because we know
we're going to have
this news article,
let's put that top
upper limit really,
really high so we'll be OK
if something goes awesome,
but we don't have to pay
for the extra awesome
if things don't go so well.
So be aware.
You need to, again, reevaluate
this on a regular basis.
You can set those bumpers
in appropriate places.
Question three--
halfway through-- there
are seven questions.
I don't think I mentioned that.
What skills do I have?
So this is where you
think deep inside yourself
and, like, what do
I actually know?
Specifically, languages
and frameworks--
I'm a giant language dork.
If you go to my Twitter profile
or you look at my conference
bio, I mentioned Prolog because
I am a giant language dork.
But at GCP, I'm on
the Advocacy Team.
And one of my primary
areas of advocacy is Ruby--
so very different.
If I was going to have to do a
database-backed website right
now, I would pick up Rails.
I know it backwards,
forwards, and inside out.
I know that I can get
something up and running
very, very quickly.
But that's not the best
solution for a lot of things.
Doing WebSockets in Rails,
until very recently,
was awful, like,
truly, truly, awful.
So if I was going
to do WebSockets,
I would have picked up
something like NodeJS.
I also have been
using Node a lot
because I've been falling deeply
in love with Cloud Functions,
and Cloud Functions
supports Node.
So think about what you know.
If you're doing data science,
Python might be a good choice.
Think about what you're
comfortable with.
Also, think about what kinds of
configurations are you used to?
So I've been asking
this question
at all of the
conference talks I've
been doing of late because
it's confusing me deeply.
Who, here, has stood
up a VM in a cloud
or actually, physically,
something they racked--
made a VM, provisioned it?
OK, less than I expected,
but still there.
Who's taken that
VM to production?
OK, so if I asked that
question five years ago,
it would have been the vast
majority of the audience.
And now that we're
in this wonderful age
of serverless and
managed services,
it's declining very
steadily over time.
No shame in having not
done that, by the way.
But if you've never done it,
and you don't want to learn it,
probably Compute Engine
is not your choice.
You can also decide
to learn stuff.
You have to make sure
you budget extra time.
You have to make
sure that you have
resources available-- meetups,
whatever-- to learn things.
And make sure you're making
that choice on purpose.
I've been helping a number of
folks over the last two years
who are like, everyone says
I should use containers.
And I'm, like,
containers are awesome.
And they're, like, this is
my first web application.
I don't know what
a Stack Traces.
And I'm like, container is not
your good choice right now.
Let's do something else.
Because you shouldn't
be using containers
unless you're comfortable
enough with your stack
that you can deal with the
fact that the container adds
an extra layer of
indirection that
makes everything
just slightly harder
if you're debugging
application code.
It makes a lot of stuff easier.
It's a good way to make
sure you're getting the most
bang for your buck out
of your infrastructure,
but it makes some things harder.
And you should make sure you go
into that with your eyes open.
Just because everyone else
says containers are awesome
does not mean containers
are awesome for you.
Just because everyone else
says serverless is awesome
does not mean that serverless
is awesome for you.
If you went to my colleague
Brian Dorsey's talk
about "where do I run
my stuff" earlier,
there was a giant slide
that said, "it depends."
And that's because it depends.
There is not one best way.
That's the thesis of this talk.
That's what we're going to be
talking about the entire time.
So we have some
language restrictions
with our compute offerings.
I wish we didn't, because
my language is not
particularly well represented.
But we are adding more languages
and more support all the time,
and it is getting better.
It's so much better than it
was 3 and 1/2 years ago when
I started at GCP.
So Google Cloud
Functions runs Node.
More languages are coming soon.
I cannot define what
soon is, I am sorry.
And when they come soon,
they will be in beta.
And I'm here to
tell you right now,
you should not use beta products
in production-- please don't.
It's a really bad idea.
I don't feel like I
should have to say that,
but people do it all the time
because they are super excited.
And then it explodes, or we
massively change the interface
or something.
So don't use beta products
in production, pretty please.
We have App Engine Standard,
which supports Java,
Python, Go, and
Node is now in beta.
So again, don't use beta
products in production, please.
But hopefully, we'll be
going GA relatively soon.
App Engine Standard
is amazing, but there
are some restrictions on the
libraries that you can use.
And both Google Cloud Functions
and App Engine Standard
don't let you write to disk.
It's becoming less
of an issue recently.
But for a long time,
people were, like, well,
I have to write to disk.
And I'm like, well,
you don't have to.
But if writing to
disk is important,
don't use those products.
If you're writing
to disk, and you're
doing something
that's based on HTTP,
you might want to rethink that.
Because at the end of the day,
HTTP is, in fact, stateless.
And writing to disk
is preserving state.
So make sure that you've
reconciled those contradictions
in your head.
App Engine Flex--
this is our, "Yes, we
can run containers,
any container you want,
in a managed fashion."
We support all of our official
languages, all seven of them.
Let's see if I can name
the Seven Dwarves--
Java, Python, Go, PHP,
Node, .NET, and Ruby.
But you can also
run anything you
can run in a container on this.
Last year, at this event,
one of my colleagues
ran Perl in a container
as part of his talk.
So really, truly,
on App Engine Flex--
we can run anything as long as
you can put it in a container.
Google Kubernetes Engine-- yes.
You can run anything there if
you can run it in a container.
And Google Compute Engine-- if
you can run it on your lappy,
you can run it on Compute
Engine, mostly, almost always.
And there are
probably some things
you can do on Compute Engine
that you can't do on your lappy
because your lappy
fits in your bag,
and you can make a really big
machine on Compute Engine.
So fourth question--
what is the happy path?
Who's heard the term
"happy path" before?
It's one of my favorites.
So happy path is the
thing that you want people
to be doing on your website.
So if you sell stuff,
that's the path
where you sell them things.
Because that's how you
make money, and that's
how your website keeps going.
If you've got some sort
of social media thing,
you probably want people
to log in, and view a feed,
and talk to their friends.
The happy path, if you've heard
the 80/20 rule, is the 80 case.
This is the stuff that
goes on most of the time.
Your "I forgot my password"
link is not the happy path.
It's important, but it
is not the happy path.
It's not where people are
spending most of their time.
And once you know what
your happy path is,
you need to instrument
the heck out of it.
First thing, minimum bar--
you should have uptime checks.
You should make sure that you
know if the site goes down.
Because if you
don't, you're going
to get angry customers
or angry marketing folks.
Don't do that.
Stackdriver Monitoring
has uptime checks
down at the Disruption Detector.
We're showing that you
can see your uptime checks
in real time with latency
from all over the globe.
Uptime checks are awesome,
but they're boring.
The next thing you
should do is, you
should monitor the
performance of the happy path.
This is where people are going
to spend most of their time,
so this is the stuff that needs
to be fast and consistent.
We have Stackdriver APM, which
is Stackdriver Application
Performance Monitoring,
if you've never
had the APM acronym before.
My favorite part of that
is Stackdriver Trace.
It's distributed tracing.
It works across microservices,
and it gives you
a nice, visual, timeline-y
representation of what's
going on with your app.
I've been doing this long
enough that I actually
wrote one of these out on
graph paper with crayons at one
of my previous jobs to
prove that we were fine
and didn't need more servers.
But it's so much better
when the computer
draws the graphic for you.
I really like Trace because it
helps me see things like N+1
query errors.
This is a really
common error that you
see in things like Django and
Rails where you have a loop,
and inside the loop,
you're doing a query
to get a single row.
So every time you go through
that loop, you do a query.
And it's much more performant
to do the query ahead of time,
pull back all of the data,
and then iterate through it.
Because queries have
I/O implications,
and they take longer.
And I have written apps
on Google Cloud Platform
that had this.
And in Trace, it's really
obvious because it's Cloud
SQL, Cloud SQL, Cloud SQL, oh--
I should not do that.
We also have
Stackdriver Profiler.
It's relatively new.
Everyone who is
using it loves it.
It's another way to see
potential performance problems
in your application.
Metrics-- so when I
worked at this startup,
we actually had a cash register
sound that played in the office
every time we made a sale.
We were new.
It was exciting.
And every time we
had to do a refund,
we played the sound backwards.
That was a metric.
There are all kinds of metrics.
Maybe it's simultaneous users,
or number of successful logins,
or a number of times someone
has gone through your checkout
path.
There are all sorts of
metrics, depending on your app,
there are ones that are
interesting or not to you.
The nice thing
about Stackdriver is
that you can take those
metrics out of your logs.
Because there's a lot of
stuff you can't actually
pull out of system data,
but it's all over the logs.
And you can make those log
messages show up in aggregated
form-- averages, means, counts--
in your dashboards as metrics.
And then you can
do alerts on them.
So that's super cool.
It's one of my favorite things
about Stackdriver right now.
And then there's SLA monitoring.
We talked about it a bit
in one of the keynotes.
There have been
other talks about it.
We have a blog post we
published last week on this.
To do SLA monitoring
correctly, you
need to know what your SLA is.
So if you have a team, you
should sit down with your team,
you should talk about
your happy path,
and you should talk about, what
is a reasonable amount of time
that those requests
should be taking?
This is a very
uncomfortable conversation.
I recommend starting
with the data you already
have and decide, is this OK?
If it's OK, you
should just make sure
that you know if it gets worse.
If it's not OK, well, you need
to put stuff in your work queue
to fix it.
And then you should
make sure that you
know if you're getting worse.
One of the places I worked,
we just had a stoplight.
We had five requests that were--
I think they made up
98% of our traffic.
And we had a
stoplight because we
knew we wanted the 95%
case on all of those
to be within a certain range.
And if it went
outside, the stoplight
turned red and that was bad.
Question five-- so what
are the rough spots
of your application?
So some of you are
thinking, I don't write
code that has rough spots.
And I'm thinking,
Awesome-- can I be you?
Because I write code that
has rough spots all the time.
There are going to
be spots where you
didn't get as much QA coverage.
Maybe it was really
hard to test it.
Maybe it was a third
party integration.
Maybe you hate automated
testing frameworks,
and you know that you
just didn't get to it.
Maybe there's that one person on
your team who's, like, my code
is perfect.
I shouldn't have to test.
I'm not going to
follow the rules.
Great.
We all have rough spots.
Google has rough spots.
Everyone has rough spots.
Just know what they
are because you
want to treat them
differently when
you're going to production.
You want to instrument them.
So one of the things I am
very passionate about-- there
are a couple of
things in this talk.
But this is one
of my favorites--
is you should know what the
rates of 5xx and 4xx errors are
compared to your
200's and your 300's.
Here's why you should know that.
I have found a lot of
production plugs using this.
My two favorites are, I
was working for a company,
and marketing sent
out a marketing email
with a deep link to the website.
Problem is, we hadn't
implemented that deep link yet.
So all of the sudden,
our 404 rates spiked.
We had instrumentation on it.
We had alerts on it.
We're like, something
is not quite right here.
Let's go fix that.
And we were able to really
quickly shove a redirect in
to make it so that all those
people that had received
that marketing message,
after the first 50 or so,
got to the right place.
They didn't just see
a 404 and think, Well,
those guys are dumb.
Another story-- I was
working in consulting.
And we were doing a
project for a company,
and we had just brought it
online for the first time.
And someone at our
contact at the company
hadn't told the IT department
that we were doing this.
So the IT guys or
gals sees a thing
on the network they
hadn't done before.
So they do the logical
thing, and they
start probing it trying to
figure out if it's secure,
right-- totally makes sense.
And we're sitting
there going, What
are people doing
to our application?
Because the 404's, the 500's--
all of the errors start
spiking through the roof.
And so we do the
exact right thing
you should do when someone's
trying to find vulnerabilities
in your website, which is,
we blocked that IP address.
And then we get a call
saying, Why did you guys block
the IT department's IP address?
Because they were doing mean
things to our application.
But then we were
able to figure out
a time when they could do the
security scan, when we knew
that they were doing
the security scan,
and it wasn't going
to affect development.
So you know-- communication.
But if that had been someone
from the big, wide, scary
internet, blocking
their IP address
would have been the
right thing to do.
And we only knew about it
because we had this kind
of monitoring in place.
Trace and Debugger-- two
features in Stackdriver--
I've talked a little
bit about Trace.
Again, it will help
you find your errors.
Debugger is the
coolest thing we have.
I am so stoked about it.
If you haven't played with
it, Stackdriver Debugger
is live application
debugging in production.
You install an agent.
It sits in the background-- it
doesn't have a lot of latency
or any latency depending on the
language-- and does nothing.
And then you're like, how
the heck did that person get
into that section of the "If?"
I don't know.
That's not supposed to happen.
And you're like, great,
Stackdriver Debugger--
you go in to the UI.
You can either run it
completely locally,
or you can hook your
cloud repo up to it,
shows you your code,
you hit a little button.
You're like, tell me what
the state of the application
is when someone gets here.
And a request goes through,
maybe from you, maybe
from a customer.
And what we do is we
capture the call stack,
all of the local variables,
all the information
that you probably
need to debug it,
and we print it out for you, and
then we let the request finish.
We don't give you
step-through debugging,
because that would be a
horrible experience for whoever
was on the other
end of that request.
But we do give you a good
sized watch window and a set
of information about it.
And a feature we added in
the last couple of months,
maybe year, is we have a
very small logging language
that you can add arbitrary log
lines to an application that
is running in production.
And the reason this
is cool is because you
don't have to redeploy.
You can do it all live.
You can do it all in the UI.
You don't actually
have to push new code.
And for anyone who's had to
instrument a bunch of code,
and then push it, and then
had all of those long lines
or whatever affect all of
your requests, this is magic.
And I'm going to take
a drink of water.
And some of you
should just think
about what we had to
do to make that work
for compiled languages like
Java and Go because it's gross.
Today, I'm like, wait, wait.
We have this for Java?
How did we do that?
And then they told me, and
I'm, like, yeah, that's gross.
And a lot of the
libraries that do this
are actually open source.
So you can go look
and see how we do it.
Like, for Ruby, this
was not scary to me.
Of course, we rewrote
classes at runtime.
We do that stuff.
It's fine.
And the other thing you
should do on your rough bits
is you should make sure that
you shorten your release
cycle as much as possible.
I've been debugging a lot
of stuff the last few weeks.
And if I have to wait
15 minutes to figure out
if my change worked,
it is a bad day for me.
So we talked about Cloud
Build in one of the keynotes.
It is my new
favoritest thing ever.
You're like, here's
a bunch of steps.
Go do that on really
big machines, Google,
and then put the stuff that
you build or make somewhere
where I can grab it later.
It's on your network, so
it's on the same network
as my production
harbor, so I don't
have to deal with latency.
It's fantastic.
There's a limited set
of stuff that's already
preconfigured for Cloud Build.
But watch this space.
There are going to be more and
more templates and examples
coming from both the
community and from Google
over the next several
months, maybe years.
I work on the languages efforts,
specifically, in advocacy.
And a bunch of us are
trying to figure out
what the right templates to give
our language communities are.
App Engine Standard has a
relatively short release cycle.
You're like, please make
this new code go here.
That's great.
Use that.
And Cloud Functions,
again, I said
it's one of my new
favoritest things.
I have been debugging some
really gross Cloud Functions
because I'm not a particularly
good JavaScript developer.
And the fact that I can edit
it in the UI, hit the, Yeah--
Try That button, and it spins
for a minute, maybe two, maybe
only 30 seconds.
And then there's a tab next
to it that says "Test."
And I click that, and
it tries the function,
and then the logs for that
request spit out underneath it.
It's great.
I can iterate doing several--
I can probably do 5 to
10 different attempts
in an hour, maybe even more.
It's fantastic.
OK.
So question six-- how
fault tolerant am I?
So this is the one that
makes everyone really,
really nervous and really,
really not OK with the fact
that I'm saying this.
I'm going to tell you
right now that you
have to accept that sometimes
things are going to go wrong.
Maybe it's not your
fault. Maybe a shark bit
through the undersea cable.
There is a story
about that happening,
and you can go find
it on the internet.
But things that are bad
are going to happen.
So you have to acknowledge
that things that are bad
are going to happen.
And you have to decide what
you're willing to accept.
If you've been to
any of the SRE talks,
you've probably heard about
the idea of error budgets.
I like error budgets.
Error budgets are fantastic.
Now, maybe you work
on an application
that keeps airplanes flying
and keeps people alive.
Awesome, you're amazing.
Your risk tolerance is
going to be lower than mine.
I make websites.
It's fine if they go
down for a little while.
Nobody's going to die.
So think about what
your fault tolerance is.
Maybe you can deal with an
arbitrary or reasonable amount
of downtime outside
of business hours,
but you really need to stay
up during business hours.
Or maybe 15 minutes a
month is all you can offer.
But you need to
know that, so you
can make the right decisions
about how much capacity
you need to provision, how
much you need to monitor,
and all that.
Once you know how
fault tolerant you are,
you can work backwards,
and figure out
what you should be monitoring.
You should monitor
as thoroughly as you
need to to make sure that
you have achieved your fault
tolerance goals.
So if you're not
particularly worried,
uptime is probably
enough for you.
But if performance is important
to your fault tolerance,
if you need to know that
everything's working
across data centers, if you
need to know latency on things,
monitor the stuff.
Monitor the stuff that
can't fail, or monitor
the stuff where you need to
talk to someone if it does fail.
If you don't take anything
else from this talk,
please take the next two
points, and write them
millions of times
until you get it.
Don't wake yourself up if you
can't do anything about it.
Alerts must be actionable.
My wonderful story
about this was,
I carried the pager for a
company for a couple of years.
And one night at, like,
2:00 AM, the pager goes off,
and, you know,
heartbeat goes up.
And the alert was "The
production disk on one
of the five production
servers is at 86% full."
OK.
And I go look at
the alert history.
And I'm like, oh, five
days ago, it was 85% full.
I don't have to do anything
about that at 2:00 AM.
There is nothing
interesting happening.
We could wait several more
weeks, and it would be fine.
So I should not have gotten
woken up for that alert.
That is an example
of a bad alert.
It was also an alert
that I configured,
so it's my own fault.
But make sure that, if
you're alerting on something,
that there is either something
technological that you can
do to fix it, or
there is someone
that you need to either be
telling that something is
going wrong or apologizing to.
That is also an action.
But if there's
nothing that you would
do in the middle of the
night if this went off,
if it can wait until
the next morning,
alert in an appropriate format.
Also, alert on
what needs to work.
If you're OK with your
forgotten password link
not working for a
couple of hours,
that should not
set your pager off.
Focus on the stuff that's really
important to work, and please
ignore the rest.
Because pager fatigue
is totally a thing,
and it's horrible
when you get it,
and it makes everyone ignore
everything that's going on.
And then something bad happens,
and everyone freaks out.
It's just-- no, please don't.
Your life will be
better if you don't.
I also like, when I'm setting up
a site, to have two dashboards.
I have a dashboard for my
happy path, my critical path.
And then I have
another dashboard
that has the entire
system holistically.
And the reason I
have this is, someone
comes running over to my desk,
and tells me that everything
is on fire, and I'm like,
oh, that is very interesting.
And then I look up
at my two dashboards.
And if the happy path dashboard
is all red and scary, yes,
everything is on fire,
and I should probably
work on that right now.
But if the holistic
dashboard is red and scary,
but the happy path
is not red and scary,
I probably have a
little bit of time
before stuff goes
really sideways.
So I can take a deep breath,
and gather my thoughts,
and get to a place
where I can actually
deal with this in an
appropriate fashion.
I find it really helps
for me to separate--
is everything on fire, or is
only the really important stuff
on fire?
Or is the thing that's
on fire interesting?
Because I like
when stuff breaks.
It's cool, but not so urgent.
So I'm going talk about
disaster recovery.
I'm not going to give you a
ton of information on this.
Go read stuff.
I'm going to tell you that all
the SREs I know would tell you
you should be in multiple
regions or zones, pretty
please.
It's better for you.
It's better for everyone.
Please make sure that you can
deploy in multiple regions
or zones.
You don't have to
have them both live.
If you don't deploy in
multiple regions or zones,
make sure that you can deploy
to a new region or zone
relatively quickly if
being up relatively quickly
is important.
Google had an outage last week.
It was a global outage, but
lots of other cloud providers,
including us, have had
regional outages before.
A good way to protect
yourself against those
is to be in multiple
regions or zones.
It's also-- if redundancy
is really important to you,
if robustness is really
important to you,
pick one of the options
that's self-healing.
Most of our things
can be self-healing
if you configure
them to be that way.
I love Kubernetes because I can
just delete VMs underneath it.
And it's like, oh, there's
a VM that is deleted.
Let me please create a new one.
It's just chill
about it; it's great.
I also-- if you're going
to do multiple regions,
one of my biggest pet
peeves about other systems
that I've used is that you
can only see one region
at a time on your screen.
I really like that GCP-- this
is, like, my only marketing
thing here.
I really like that GCP.
It shows you everything.
You saw, in the
keynote on Tuesday,
when they showed the
Kubernetes on-prem,
that you could see two different
clusters at the same time
in different regions.
I can't tell you
the number of times
I have lost a VM because
I created it in a region
that I'm not currently
looking at in other providers.
And then disaster
recovery is a complete lie
unless you practice it.
I deleted a production
database at midnight.
And the only reason that
I did not completely
freak out and lose
my brain was that I
had practiced restoring a
backup on my local machine
multiple times.
I'd done it on a
staging machine.
So I took a deep breath,
got myself a glass of tea,
and started the restore, and
then emailed my boss and said,
sorry, we're going to
be out for a while.
I should have it back
up by 1:00, maybe 2:00.
So the last thing I have on my
list of questions-- and this
is the one that
everyone messes up.
Where are my secrets?
Everyone's got secrets.
Secrets might be things
like service account keys.
It may be API keys for
third-party services.
And the big one is user info.
Hi, I am likely to be
a user of at least one
of your guys's
products at one point.
Please don't leak my data.
I would very much
appreciate that.
So where do secrets end up?
Secrets end up all
sorts of awesome places.
Secrets end up in
source control.
I have checked in a GCP
service account before.
Yes, once you have
done that, you
need to provision a new key, and
delete that, and never use it
again.
You have just shared it
with the entire internet.
It's a password.
We don't share those.
Secrets frequently end up on
development and build servers.
And you're like,
well, that's OK.
Except, I worked at a
company where we had
one of our dev boxes stolen.
Someone stole it on a
subway or something.
And if we had had any
user info or any API
keys on that machine,
they would have
been immediately compromised.
So try not to let
secrets get on dev boxes.
It is a really bad idea.
The one that happens a lot--
a lot, a lot, a lot--
and has happened recently
to a relatively
large tech company
is that secrets end up in logs.
Frequently, this is
personal information.
So think about it this way.
Someone submits a form.
Do you log the post body?
A lot of frameworks and
applications do by default.
Anything in that
post body is now
likely in plain
text in your logs.
So my password, my credit card,
my address, all of that may
have just been
dumped to your logs.
No, we don't do that.
I have done it.
I felt very guilty about it,
and we fixed it within an hour.
It was a long time ago,
like, 15 years ago.
Same thing with alerts--
if you have a 500 error, do you
take a whole entire snapshot
of the request and then
throw that in the alert
that you're sending out
to the person on-call?
Again, that's probably
got some stuff in it
that you shouldn't
be doing that with.
Because if you're sending it
out to an alerting system,
you're automatically sharing
all of that info with whatever
the alerting system is.
Think about it.
I'm not saying you
shouldn't do it.
But make sure you're
doing it consciously.
Email-- I worked
at a company where
we emailed every
piece of user feedback
to every employee
at the company.
No.
That's a bad idea as well.
We ended up running it
through an anonymizer
and then doing it, which
was actually quite awesome
because some of the
feedback was great.
And then databases-- you're
like, well, of course,
personal information
ends up in databases.
Please see my comment about
dev boxes getting stolen.
If you let people
install a production copy
on their local machine, make
sure that everything in there
is anonymized.
Ideally, you would have a
separate database of test info
that they could use for testing.
So how do you
protect your secrets?
There's some stuff that you just
have to do in your engineering
practices.
They have to be done in
the application layer.
I'm sorry, we don't have
magic stuff for that yet.
I am sure they will come
up with something soon.
They seem to come up with
magic stuff all the time.
But we do have the Metadata
Service and Kubernetes Secrets
APIs.
Metadata Service is one of
my favorite things about GCP.
I can say, here, put this
SSH key on all of my boxes.
Oh, that guy left.
Take that SSH key off
of all of my boxes.
And I don't have to
reprovision machines.
Especially when
I was consulting,
we were constantly
reprovisioning machines
as people cycled on
and off the project.
You can also use a CLI.
I like using the web
interface because I'm lazy.
Kubernetes Secrets
is a little confusing
because a lot of people
have opinions about it.
But I've talked to
enough of those people
now that I actually believe the
way they're doing it is good.
There are a couple
ways to do it.
The way I like doing it is
you set up some secrets,
and then you can access those.
There are different
ways that you get access
to that information.
You can do
environment variables,
or you can also have them
mounted as a file system
that you can, then, pull from
as part of your container.
There are a couple
ways to do it.
It's great.
Just take a deep
breath if you're like,
this is the weirdest
way to do this.
They've thought about it a lot.
And this is one of the few times
I will say, give them a shot.
You don't have to agree,
but at least try it.
So I told you we were going
to have a review at the end.
Compute-- Cloud Functions--
you can use JavaScript.
JavaScript is awesome.
Python is coming soon.
It scales from zero to
lots and lots and lots.
I believe that is
a technical term.
I really like the speedy
deployment cycle on this one.
And if you can get into
the small functions, lots
of people working on small
pieces thing, it's great.
Some people can't get
their heads around it.
It took me a while, but
I think I'm there now.
Compute Engine-- it's a VM.
It can run stuff you
run on a computer.
You can make it whatever
size and shape you want.
We have sliders for that.
If you're going
to do this, check
out managed instance groups.
They have health checks
that you can use.
If you use the health checks,
you can get self-healing,
and you can also
get autoscaling.
And so you get all the
niceties that people
talk about with some of
the managed services,
but you just have it on a VM.
VMs are familiar to many of us.
We know how to make a VM work.
It's awesome.
And it's cheaper, but it
might need more of your time
to handle it or
set up provisioning
scripts in something like
Puppet, Chef, or Ansible.
App Engine-- we
have two flavors--
standard and flexible.
It's really easy to deploy.
You type "gcloud app deploy."
If it's one of the languages
we know, we say, It
looks like you're
running blah, would you
like us to write a
configuration file for that?
It supports all
languages in some form,
and it supports anything you
can run in a container on Flex.
App Engine Standard
scales down to zero,
so anything that runs
on App Engine Standard,
you can scale down to zero,
but it has restrictions
on what libraries you can use.
Logging, error reporting,
and basic monitoring
come by default with
App Engine Standard,
and they're very easy to
set up for App Engine Flex.
And it does the load balancing
and networking for you.
My least favorite
part of running on VMs
is setting up networking.
And so, if someone else
does that, that's great.
Kubernetes Engine--
it runs containers.
I was supposed to have a
picture of a container ship
or something on
this slide, but eh.
It does autoscaling
and self-healing.
It can't scale down to zero,
but it can scale down to not
very much.
There are no
restrictions on what
you can run as long as you
can put it in a container.
And it does the load balancing
and networking for you.
So I actually end up
running a lot of stuff
in Kubernetes
Engine because I get
to run whatever I want
in whatever way I want,
and it does service
discovery for me,
and I don't have to set up
load balancing and networking.
It's fantastic.
Stackdriver-- the other main
thing I talked about today--
this is our operations,
monitoring, logging, debugging,
it "helps you make
stuff better and know
what's going on" platform.
Stackdriver
Monitoring-- alerting
via many different means,
you can get emails.
You can get something
dumped into pager duty
or into one of your
team chat apps.
You can set up
custom dashboards.
You have system-level
monitoring-- so
how much CPU am I using?
How many bytes are going over
the wire-- but also application
level monitoring-- what's
my ratio of errors?
What's my average latency?
What's the latency
of the 95% case?
Because we all know that, if
you just look at the mean,
that one request that
took five minutes
is just going to
break everything.
It's multi-cloud-- you
can use it on AWS and GCP.
And for a lot of
the features, you
can actually use that
on-prem or anywhere
you can run your stuff if
you install the libraries.
If you're going to do
this, remember alerts
should be actionable.
And you should probably set
up something that vaguely
looks like a system
overview, so you can quickly
know what the heck is going on.
Stackdriver Logging--
log aggregation--
you can search stuff,
pretty good query language.
You can export to
files or you can
export to BigQuery, which is
really, super, crazy powerful.
You can feed the logs into
metrics and monitoring.
I talked about that earlier.
Again, multi-cloud--
use our libraries.
You can also use it on-prem
if you use our libraries.
Tips-- handle your
secrets with care.
Please don't dump
secrets to logs
unless you can control access
to those very, very well.
Trace-- this is the tracing
through microservices thing.
This lets you see the
timeline of what's
going on in your application.
It also has cool features like
period-over-period performance.
If someone's like, the
website is slower this week,
and you can say, No.
I can impose a
latency graph over top
from last week and this week.
And the answer to that is no.
Or you can say, oh
yeah, sorry about that.
I'll fix it.
You can also debug bottlenecks
and timeouts quickly.
For some sets of
errors, we may actually
predict what the
problem is and say,
hey, you might consider
adding an index here.
But you need to
instrument your app,
unless you're running
on App Engine Standard.
And the recommended agent's
going to be different
depending on your language.
For some, we're using
OpenCensus, for some,
we're using Stackdriver
Trace Agents.
I believe were moving in
the direction of OpenCensus
for everything.
Stackdriver Debugger-- this is
the live production debugging.
Please go and try this.
No one believes me,
and it is amazing.
But again, you need
to instrument your app
with the agent.
A lot of people get a
little twitchy about that.
They're like, well,
why should I have
this running in the background?
You should have it running
in the background so
that, when something
goes wrong, you
don't have to do another
relay cycle to debug it.
And then Stackdriver Error
Reporting is crash aggregation.
Something broke.
It groups all the stuff
that's vaguely similar,
it takes representative traces,
it can link you to the logs,
it can link to your bug tracker.
So you can start from,
something is wrong,
and then look at all the
other tools that are all
linked together to debug it.
If you've ever had to assemble
a performance monitoring,
regular monitoring,
log aggregation tool
from a bunch of
different toolkits,
having everything talk to each
other is really, really nice
and saves a lot of time.
It has alert backoff built in.
So if you do something
really stupid,
and you're getting
a lot of alerts,
you won't actually have
your pocket explode on you
every time someone hits
the path that's broken.
And it's automatically set
up for App Engine Standard.
It's really easy to set
up for App Engine Flex.
You just get grab the library,
and you shove it in your app.
Stackdriver Profiler--
people are super into this.
It helps you improve
code performance.
So that's probably
why they're into it.
It's also really easy to
use and uses flame graphs
that people are used to.
We have it for Java,
Go, and Node right now.
I would assume more is coming.
I can't actually give
you a timeline on that.
And that's what I have.
Thank you for coming.
I know it's the end
of the second day,
and this is a giant,
crazy conference
and very overwhelming.
I appreciate your time.
Again, I'm Aja.
I'm on the Application
Development Advocacy Team.
So I am not an Ops
person, but I'm
happy to answer any
of your questions.
You can email me at Thagomizer--
just spelled exactly how it
sounds-- @google.com.
Or you can tweet at
me, @the_thagomizer.
And I have a couple
of minutes at the end
after I'm done talking, to hand
out some stickers to people,
but I actually have an
appointment very shortly.
So thank you very much.
I appreciate your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]